all right bend over I'm gonna wipe it  but you put the goldfish back in the  bowl don't eat the play-doh where did  this a cup of dirt come from band-aids  are not stickers the oven is not a  playhouse for your stuff to it  don't you feel those big hands out of  the toilet why are there Legos in the  peanut butter  Melissa anymore pooping stop licking the  dog spit that out in my hand right now I  know you gotta go just hold it okay well  you went you wait no all right stop  kissing the dog on the mouth those gummy  bears aren't gonna fit up your nose take  the headphones off the dog we do not eat  cookies out of the trash the next time  you want to say hi to the neighbors you  have to put pants on you do not equips  me fine in the car seat integrated give  it yeah that's cute okay I swear it boy  I will drive me to supermarket and leave  you there